hi everyone sal here welcome to the i
guess homeroom with sal uh live stream
the name keeps evolving a little bit a
couple of quick announcements first of
all uh we we were hoping to have lester
holt today uh but him being in the news
industry there's been some uh news i
believe that has taken him away so
unfortunately we've had to postpone that
i was really looking forward to that
interview but i'm hoping we will have it
in the next couple of weeks uh the other
standard announcements uh i will make so
instead of lester holt you're just going
to get me so we're going to do an ask me
anything so you can even start putting
the questions you have on youtube and
facebook below the live stream and we'll
get to that in
to a few minutes and literally ask about
anything the other announcement is my
standard announcement just a reminder
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization that we exist because of
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so
please think about making a donation to
khan academy i want to make a special
shout out to several organizations that
have
stepped up when they learned that we
were running at a deficit even before
the covid crisis and that deficit only
grew as our server costs and our our
need to support more folks grew through
the crisis special thanks to bank for
america google.org att fasting of
artists and actually the amgen
foundation as well and then my last
announcement is uh some enterprising
khan academy team members
have realized that
a lot of what we do in the live stream
makes for a good podcast with a little
bit of editing here and there so if you
are into listening to podcasts you want
to have listen some of our or
interesting conversations that we've had
with some really impressive people from
the car or wherever else
please check out homeroom with sal the
podcast which you can find wherever you
typically find podcasts in your life
so with that uh let's let's start this
ama so
the first question there's already a
couple questions that are coming in
actually this was a question we had from
before but it's a good one adarsh
persona from youtube had asked hi sal i
heard that it is possible to take an sat
in seventh grade
do you recommend this
my
view is it depends on your motivation i
think if you are a seventh grader and
you're just curious about it and
you you wanna have kind of a run at
taking the sct i think that's fine
that's great
and there's a lot of good things that
can come of that if if you take it it'll
build your comfort with the test
you'll
essentially be entering into high school
with a little bit more information a
little bit more context so that's that's
a good thing there's also a lot of
programs that you can get into if you do
reasonably well on the sat four as a
middle schooler uh which which are
pretty neat uh there's the the duke
talent search i believe i think johns
hopkins has a program i believe stanford
has a program so there's a bunch of
programs like that so if you're
if you're uh you know someone who who
likes to be on the precocious side of
things i i don't think there's harm in
taking it
now the only reason i wouldn't take it
is if you feel some type of pressure or
stress around it if you're like oh i've
got to take it because everyone else is
taking it but it stresses me out and
i can't then i wouldn't i wouldn't i
wouldn't do it but generally speaking i
do advocate
in middle school it's not a bad idea to
take it it just makes you familiar with
something you learn a little bit about
stuff you learn what you know what you
don't know and it's completely okay to
take a test that you haven't learned
some of the material the sat for example
in math goes up to algebra 2 and really
just the core of algebra ii and so most
seventh graders would not have seen that
material yet
but it's interesting to see it on a test
and then see it later in your classroom
i i would also say that um you know if
you're going to take the sat you try try
to brush up a little bit or learn a
little bit of algebra you'd be surprised
how far it'll it'll get you so but i
don't think it's a bad idea i think it
could be interesting as long as you have
a
a a good mindset uh going into it
so
from
from youtube george georgie grogan asked
do you think khan academy works better
for younger or older people
um
depends you know we we have stuff on
khan academy for almost every age group
we have khan academy kids and we have
some really cool efficacy studies there
and so you know if you have a
three-year-old four-year-old
five-year-old six-year-old i highly
recommend khan academy kids if we're
talking about
you know say learning algebra one on
khan academy um
i think you know we do see a lot of
adults
that you know when they went through it
the first time in eighth or ninth grade
and they might not have perceived
themselves as strong
math students when they do it as adults
they have a little bit more maturity
they're a little bit more driven they
they they're they're internally
motivated um
they're often very very successful uh at
re learning things that they you know
that they
they didn't learn the first time in
school i think if you're a student
it's really you the degree to which
you can
um
you can motivate yourself to really do
the work and we see a lot of students
who are very capable of doing that in a
lot of ways that skill that ability to
kind of drive your own learning is is
maybe even more important than the math
itself
so i wouldn't say it necessarily works
better or worse for older younger people
but i think
you know everyone needs different
degrees of support
you know for folks who are very
motivated and very driven regardless of
their age uh and regardless of their
capability their starting capability i
think it can work very well and then i
think uh you know other folks need
different degrees of support and it
might be supports from their teachers
supports from peers obviously all of us
at khan academy are constantly thinking
of
new mechanics new ways of showing the
information so make it more as engaging
as possible uh so you know uh but but i
don't i i it's not obvious that you know
older or younger is a benefit
from youtube az asks
what are you planning to do after
quarantine
after quarantine
so
you know i've said this a couple of
times in the live streams there's
certain obviously what we're going
through as a world is a horrible and
bizarre situation
but there's certain aspects of it that
that i'm actually starting to get used
to and and in certain ways enjoy
you know the fact that my kids are at
home i'm working from home
uh you know my wife is working from home
two or three days a week now
it's it's at first it was hard because
you know sometimes i'm recording a video
and all of a sudden my five-year-old
screaming you know 20 feet away it can
kind of mess up your concentration
but one i've kind of gotten used to that
a little bit and now i've started to
enjoy uh hearing
my five-year-old scream or when i have
to take when i get a break or you know
get lunch
i can i get to see them or spend a
little bit time with them or take a
break with them or take a walk with them
and you know i'm realizing that you know
time goes by very very fast you're you
know if you are a kid your childhood
would go by fast and if you're a parent
your kid's childhood is going to go by
very fast and i think to be able to
spend this extra time with family
even if it's incidental you know we see
each other while we're you know
eating lunch and things like that i
think that's going to be something that
i i want to retain as much as i can of a
postcovid um
i i think you know something about covet
has made us connect with a lot of
friends and family that we otherwise
wouldn't frankly wouldn't have connected
with at least as regularly on zoom or
whatever else i hope that's something
that uh keep postcovid uh you know i've
always been the person who likes
spending a lot of time outdoors and so
you know i live out here in northern
california where the weather is quite
nice and i've always been at like you
know pre-cove and i've used to go to
gatherings and say why are we outside
and people say it's 60 degrees it's so
cold and i'm like no but it's it's
outside it's nature let's we
i'll so i i i hope you know i i actually
like the fact in kova that we're forced
to go outside and and if we do socialize
you know socially distanced in a park in
a backyard
um
the stuff that the stuff that um i i i
want to get yeah so those are my those
are my
my big ones um obviously the things that
i miss right now are
you know my mom lives in new orleans
she's by herself
uh you know i would love her to be able
to come and visit us or us to visit her
but obviously you know she's in a
high-risk group and it would be hard to
travel on a plane right now because of
that
so i think that's the stuff that that's
that i can't wait we can to you know we
get through that part because i think
that it's taking a a big tax on on
families who are who are apart right now
and i know i'm very lucky uh in
considering all else's going in the
world a lot of people are you know
really having i can above and beyond the
the covet hardship or the coveted fear
and the quarantine hardship are having
economic hardships um
uh that i'm you know i that that's gonna
be huge when we get back to normalcy
people are gonna be able to you know
restaurants will reopen et cetera et
cetera
so
from facebook tracy harris is saying i
have some students who are still
struggling with mastering their
multiplication division facts how can i
help them
great question tracy and i would say you
know
we do not talk enough about the
importance of things like math facts and
i think sometimes
let's call it the education
establishment
we don't talk about it as much because
it feels so
simple or it's not as you know
sophisticated as talking about the
deeper standards uh you know of
integrating knowledge and going higher
up bloom's taxonomy but i can't tell you
how many young people i've seen you know
i've visited sixth grade classrooms
where it's pretty clear that a majority
of the school students really didn't
have fluency in in some of their core
math facts around addition or
multiplication and because of that it
was just holding them back and they were
getting and even if they knew how to
kind of think about the problem and
construct
equations
you know when they hit 9 times 6 they
would just kind of
you know write 56 instead of 54 and get
the whole thing wrong
and and so it's super important uh i i
think you know to some degree the cove
is a really good time for everyone to
make sure that they have really strong
foundations including some middle school
i've met high school students who
who really don't have fluency at their
multiplication facts
um
and so you know what i would highly
recommend doing
is making it social you know it's it's
kind of very old school sit down with
the flash cards i think you can order
them on online get some multiplication
flash cards and sit down with your with
your child and and go through them and
say we're gonna do this ten minutes a
day you know what i've been doing with
my a nine year old who's you know she's
she essentially knows her multiplication
but it's not fluent yet uh you know in
the morning of breakfast i'll go six
times eight real fast and i'll just do
two or three uh every morning just uh
just to see if she can get get her flu
she gets a little annoyed she rolls her
eyes but then she'll go 48.
uh so it's and and the 48 is coming a
little faster and you know anyone who
spent a lot of time on khan academy
would know i'm not an advocate generally
of memorization or rote memorization of
things i it's very important to have an
intuition and to really understand
what's going on but multiplication facts
obviously the students should understand
what multiplication is
and and how you can even derive if you
know that 6 times 8 is 48 if you want to
know 6 times 9 well you set another 6
you get to 54 but at some point in your
life it has to come very very automatic
otherwise you're going to be spending
too much cognitive load on the
multiplication versus the the higher
order things that you're you're you're
you're trying to do
so let's see there's uh youtube az
another question from az you ask a lot
of questions about quarantine but these
are good questions what's one thing
you've learned during quarantine
um well depends what you mean learn if
it's kind of like learning about life
you know i talked a lot about it is that
it's nice to spend more time with the
family nice to connect with you know
past friends and family over over video
conference
uh
i'm finding
that you know obviously the workplaces
had to go everyone's workplace where
possible has had to go
remote especially people who've had you
know traditionally desk jobs so to speak
um
it's seeming for cert for certain folks
it's becoming a lot harder and for other
folks they're actually enjoying it
because it's less of a commute they're
actually feeling more productive
uh so you know it's been interesting
that a lot of our societal norms
you know which probably wouldn't have
been questioned deeply before but
quarantine has forced us to question it
i i think you know i've i've learned
that uh you know the the standard
assumptions about it are are
are maybe not 100 true
if you're talking about you know like
knowledge that i've gained during
quarantine
let's see what what am i
what are my you know i i off off the
cuff i don't have any like
new factoids that i've i've learned some
things in this live stream situation
uh you know it was uh
but but yeah i haven't i i i'll keep
thinking about that question
so
the
from facebook misty schwaller asks what
are you currently reading so i think
i've answered this before and it tells
you it'll tell you how long this book is
the fact that it's been several weeks
that i'm going to give you the same
answer i'm reading shantharam uh by i
think his name is gregory david roberts
is the authors
now for young people i definitely do not
recommend reading it it is a very
it's about someone who escaped from
prison in australia and then kind of
joins the
bombay mafia and in some ways it kind of
celebrates the vibrancy of life in india
in the in the 80s um but there's a lot
of darkness to it a lot of violence to
it i'm not normally not a fan of
violence but a friend recommended that i
read it there's some interesting
philosophical aspects of the book uh but
it's a long book um and it gets a little
darker than i normally like
but that's that is that is what i am
that is what what i have been reading
i'm almost done uh i'm i'm i'm eager to
think about what i will read next though
i'm open to any recommendations
um
from facebook hussein rumi can you
recommend some books from your shelf
yes and some people have wondered is
that a real shelf you know this world of
zoom backgrounds but that this is this
is very much a real shelf and this shelf
has some of my favorite books
on it
you know there's a bunch of science
fiction books here so
you know this is
we have ender's game which is
if you anyone hasn't read ender's game i
envy you because you get to read it now
uh and i think this is appropriate for
anyone maybe in middle school and above
but if you're even if you're 50 and if
you haven't read ender's game you will
love ender's game and the book is
normally is the case is much better than
the movie and i have the other the other
books and the um enders actually have
two copies of ender's game here
i'd let you borrow one if we weren't so
socially distanced uh but then i have
the other the other
books in the in the series where ender
travels through space and
comes in
contact but i just have a ton of i have
the foundation series here so that's my
science fiction i mean there's a ton
that you're not seeing i have
uh what do i have this name of the wind
patrick rothfuss that's more fantasy but
highly highly recommend it
lifespan david sinclair we had him on
his guest couple weeks ago
uh then we have you probably can't see
all of
the the the books here the gene by
siddhartha mukherjee
uh yeah but but that's just some of it i
don't wanna
bore y'all for forever war joe haldeman
all interesting books
let's see
from youtube spirit lifter i like your
username
what is the best way to do independent
work at home if your parents aren't home
uh so
what what i would you know i i don't you
know sometimes your parents could be a
distraction
it's uh but sometimes obviously parents
can help you help you stay focused and
and provide the environment
so you know spirit lifter i don't know
how old you are or kind of what are what
type of independent work you are trying
to accomplish at home but my advice is
is try to build a habit you know we've
i've talked to this researcher who talks
about the pomodoro technique and it's
named after this this timer is shaped
like a tomato a pomodoro tomato and it's
this notion of set a regular time where
you're going to be able to focus on your
goals try to do it in 20 minutes spurts
say okay the next 20 minutes i'm going
to work and then after that 20 minutes
you set a timer of put it on your phone
or something on their computer and then
give yourself a break let yourself do
something you enjoy then do another 20
minutes and that's a really good way of
not procrastinating and then when you
are doing those 20 minutes and hopefully
it's at the same time you have good
lighting you have good posture you're
not like slouched on the bed or on the
couch you're doing it at a desk or a
table uh that um
you know just just
try
uh
well i would say just just the habit of
of staying engaged even at first it
might be a little bit difficult slowly
that habit will will build and you will
be able to
make make progress on your work i think
it doesn't hurt to set goals per day per
week per month uh you know check out
having a checklist for the day is a
great way to kind of have a bit of a
dopamine hit every time you accomplish
something and it kind of builds momentum
i've talked about this in previous live
streams you know i like to start my day
with some easy wins i always make my bed
because i'm like there i've already done
something i've made my bed and something
i'm going to benefit from in about 16
hours
i you know i i'm pretty ritualistic
about you know my morning run you know
doing some meditation doing some
push-ups brushing my teeth
making the bed uh et cetera et cetera so
i think some of you know the more that
you can kind of build these habits and
these patterns and get some wins and
check some stuff off of your checklist
early on the better
so let's see
other other questions
so
musaki yamamoto
asks hey sal would you send your kids to
school if you lived in a high case state
interesting question um my kid's school
is actually you know we live i think in
a
california is having high cases when you
look at it per capita it's reasonably
high
our county is
is
not like off the charts high but it's
having cases the city i live in in
mountain view actually has a relatively
low incidence i think they've only had a
100 or so cases in a population of i
believe 75 000 if i have my numbers
right i might be wrong uh
so the way i think about it is
the the evidence we're seeing is that
the youngest kids are
there's not a lot of evidence that we're
seeing that they are the spreaders you
know they usually are the spreaders for
things like the cold and the flu but
most of the the data that i've seen is
that they aren't the spreaders of kovid
and those are also the kids that
probably benefit the most from in-person
social interaction
and you know i'm lucky as i mentioned i
live in northern california the
weather's very good it's kind of
you know
most days of the in the summer the
weather's in the 70s and early and low
80s and in the winter it's in the 60s
and so
i think for the younger kids
you know some type of outdoor schooling
that still takes all the precautions
could be very interesting and i know the
the school my kids go to they are
looking at that for the youngest kids
for the kindergarteners first and second
graders
and they're trying to get a variance
from the state that would allow them to
serve that and i and i think i you know
you know this is just my family everyone
has to make the right choices um i would
be open to that as a parent but i think
as you get to older students given where
we are at covent right now especially if
you're not indoor if you're not outdoors
if you're indoors
i'd be very concerned about that and i
wouldn't
i wouldn't feel comfortable sending my
kids uh to something that's spending a
lot of time indoors um
where given given where where the where
covid is but uh you know the more time
out outdoors socially distanced masks on
feels like it it could work uh in a lot
in a lot of circumstances uh but but
yeah that's current thinking it's it's
we're all we're all struggling with the
same questions right now
but you know one thing that what that i
think is interesting is even with social
distancing
you know as i mentioned especially those
young kids frankly everyone needs social
interactions
you know if you have local parks if if
you have a backyard
you know meeting with
a small group of folks you know just one
other family uh socially distanced with
masks on i think is is a good way to get
some of that social interaction that i
think frankly we all need but kids
probably need it especially
so
from facebook julius
apologies if i'm not pronouncing this
correctly serniakis
our college-level math courses in the
plans well jewish we do have some uh
college-level math courses depending
whether you consider college level we
obviously have
statistics calculus we actually have
multi-variable calculus we're actually
going to be launching exercises for that
soon we also have videos and
differential equations linear algebra so
it kind of gets into your freshman
sophomore level
um
college level classes i do hope
eventually you know our focus is really
doing the k through 12 and then a little
bit of that early college i do hope
eventually khan academy is able to add
some of the more advanced math classes
uh you know in my mind that's when math
really gets interesting uh and i i miss
some of those courses and i would love
nothing more than to kind of
re-dive deep into those courses uh and
and cover some of that with y'all
so
from facebook shannon c beck asks or
says google has started offering free
certificates for career paths and things
like data analytics or project
management do you think this will
eventually be commonplace and a real
alternative to a costly college
education
simple answer is yes and i don't you
know i don't think it's going to be an
either or i think people are going to
try to do combinations of both but i
think you're going to see a lot of
people with college degrees try to get
some of these certificates and if if
employers like google or the microsoft's
or the facebooks of the world said yeah
we'll hire you if you are able to
achieve this certificate then yeah that
will have a lot of cachet maybe even
more than a college degree so and i
think that'll be healthy if there's more
paths
more variety of ways to
essentially build your skills and have
economic opportunity college will always
be a path and a lot of great things
about college but for certain people the
costs the time
the things that it focuses on might not
be exactly right so i'm always a big fan
of you know a larger diversity of
opportunity and paths
so
so from
youtube ayano aishi forever says mr sal
i'm really suffering with the sct the
english section do you have any tips for
it
well it depends how much time you have
for it i mean the english section of the
sct it really is if you if you read a
lot
um
and and your and your you know your kind
of language usage is solid in terms of
kind of grammar language usage
you should do okay you know i think one
thing that hurts a lot of people is
maybe reading speed and there
i would say just practice practice
practice you know you practice will will
only benefit you we see that in the data
on the official sat practice that you
know we do up with in partnership with
the college board that the more people
practice the more that they do the
recommended activity the more that they
take practice tests the more that they
really focus on practicing skills at
kind of their learning edge
those students are growing the most so
that's what i would recommend you and
you know to earlier questions about how
do you do that build a habit say every
day i'm going to do if the verbal or the
english section is what's giving you
trouble every day i'm going to do an
hour you know by hook or by crook
every day i'm going to do an hour uh and
i think after a several weeks of that
you're definitely going to notice
improvement your reading speed is going
to improve you're going to
just feel more comfortable and less
stressed in the test as well
so
there's
from facebook sandra sand says
does khan academy only five minutes left
time goes by fast does khan academy have
a larger strategy or plan to support
remote learning during the pandemic
the simple answer sandra is yes we're
trying you know we're doing the work
we've always been doing with teachers
and districts and parents and families
we've been also doing these learning
plans we've been running webinars for
parents and teachers on how to do
distance learning uh we are um expect an
op-ed for me in a major newspaper soon
about what what good uh distance
learning could look like uh we are
actually publishing a study on
you know that distance learning not just
using khan academy but also using live
video conferences what what what is the
best practice there
we've obviously just published our get
ready for grade level courses
to allow
students and teachers to make sure
students have all their prerequisites
filled so they're ready for grade level
any gaps that they might have accrued
over over covet or even before that
i've talked about the project
schoolhouse.world this is a project it's
not officially part of khan academy it's
a separate volunteer driven project
right now maybe one day it'll be pum
become part of pecan academy but it was
catalyzed by this covid situation where
you have khan academy it's a place where
kids and families can go to get their
practice to get supports they have hints
they have solutions they have videos
they have articles but what about live
sessions with a real teacher a real
tutor and that's what the goal
schoolhouse.world is it's a place where
students can go
and pick which areas they need help in
and they can get free live group
tutoring sessions with a vetted tutors
who are volunteers
so anyone's interested in that highly
recommend going to schoolhouse.world but
this is kind of the portfolio stuff that
we're trying to do in preparation for
what's going to clearly be a very
strange
back to school
season or or year we want to make sure
that khan academy is there for as much
practice and learning as possible and we
can help provide some guidance and a
view of how that can fit into a more
holistic picture for teachers and and
families
so let's see
from jewel from facebook julie frisk is
there a best are there best practices
for distance learning for high school it
seems that they would be more successful
if they were taking fewer classes rather
than the typical nine periods so julia i
couldn't agree more with your intuition
i think in this i think frankly even in
normal times nine periods is like that's
that's a lot of breath and a lot of
stress
that's not a good idea um it's much
better to do a few courses and be able
to focus on them and especially in a
time of covid you know what i've been
telling people at all grade levels at
all age levels is focus first and
foremost on the math the reading and the
writing make sure those on atrophy if
you can put in even 40 if you're a high
school student let's call it 45 minutes
a day of solid
active work practice in each of those
math reading and writing every day
you're going to not atrophy and you'll
probably progress and the reading and
the writing for sure can be very low
tech it could be go find a book list of
books appropriate for your grade level
or whatever reading level you're at
read those books find a group of people
that you can talk about them with
hopefully your teacher is leading you
through this but even if you're not
getting that support find some students
some peers who want to go on this
journey with you or some families if
you're a parent with of a high schooler
that will do this with you the writing
every week pick something to write about
uh and you could you know mix it up
through the year i'm going to write a
couple short stories i'm going to write
a couple of opinion pieces i'm going to
write a analysis and a you know of
whether we should open schools or
something like that and and put them on
a blog put them on medium or something
and send them to all your friends and
family and get your get feedback from
them and ask for feedback how could this
be better how can i improve this and
iterate on it i think if you do that
you're you're not going to atrophy and
you're actually going to develop a lot
of skills and then once you have your
legs under yourself there then i would
layer on you know maybe one science and
one um
one social science you know a history
and you know whatever science you're
working on whether it's physics
chemistry biology and if you do that
that's really solid especially while we
go through this pandemic and make sure
that you have enough time for sleep
enough time for socializing enough time
for exercise time with your family
because i think the biggest race we have
right now is just people burning out and
the mental health issues that might
happen because of quarantine so yeah i i
agree with your intuition to to kind of
focus on doing fewer things but doing
them better and not stressing ourselves
out or spreading ourselves too thin in
this very very difficult time
so it looks like we're almost out of
time
uh let's see if there's any questions i
can answer
any let's see from youtube
it's a there's a lot of numbers in this
username t0 rick's cane 3s
do you have any suggestions for
remembering factual information in
subjects like history
i'm not the best memorizer in the world
so take anything i have to say with the
grade of salt but what i find is the
more ways that you can represent
knowledge to yourself and the more
connections you can draw the more that
you will retrain and you know when you
look at these people who are like you
know guinness book of world record
memorizers what they'll tell is they
have visualizations they do so they're
trying to memorize a list of objects
like a cat a clock
you know spaghetti
and shoe the way that they will memorize
that is that they'll say okay i'm going
to go they'll visualize a story that
they walk into a room and then the cat
comes and
it meows and just as it meows you notice
that there's a clock right behind the
cat and so you enter the cat the room
you look at the clock and you realize oh
my god it's time for spaghetti i can
smell the spaghetti let me enter into
the kitchen and have the spaghetti and
so when you when you
the
analogy the good thing about history is
that history already has a narrative
with it you don't have to make one up
with some you know cat and a clock and
spaghetti history there are connections
and so what i would recommend you do is
don't just memorize that you know world
war one started in 1914 and you know the
kennedy was you know
inaugurated in in 1961 you know just
blindly or memorized facts think about
what else was going on in the world
think about okay in
in 1917
what was the state of technology
visualize it think about wow you know
that was two years before the spanish
flu hit um and what was you know what
was it like to live there and you know
what was going on in other parts of the
world where maybe there weren't at war
or other parts of the world where your
history books aren't covering the more
connections you draw um the more that
you'll have a frame and and then those
those years and those dates and those
names and those places will kind of very
naturally
fit fit into place
so unfortunately we're all out of time
this always goes much faster i guess i
like to you know answer questions uh but
thanks so much for joining uh the live
stream today once again my apologies for
those of y'all hoping to see lester holt
that obviously would have been an
improvement
over over just me uh but we are hoping
to get him soon he had to uh delay
because of uh some some breaking
breaking news uh but i look forward to
continuing this shortly so thanks
everyone for joining this this ama this
ask me anything livestream
you